ach ja leute was ihr euch noch fragen
wollte und zwar wer ist denn von euch
alles auf dem video der in circa zwei
wochen
lasst mich das so einfach mal und in den
kommentaren wissen und jetzt viel spaß
mit dem video erhöhte was geht ab jetzt
willkommen bei an neuen video hier mal
wieder auf einem kanal und so ja ich
weiß gar nicht so ganz genau wo ich
anfangen soll auf jeden fall werde ich
in letzter zeit ab und zu
beziehungsweise schon er öfter von
irgendwelchen leuten die ich eigentlich
gar nicht kenne
auf seinem facebook account auf meiner
seite geschrieben und es geht halt sehr
oft um irgendwelche probleme wie man
halt ein mädchen ansprechen soll oder
wie man sich in gewissen situationen
verhalten soll
und ja ich habe einfach weil die top
drei fragen rausgesucht die will ich
jetzt mal im video beantworten was ich
so darüber denke ich wünsche euch viel
ganz viel spaß und das sollte wirklich
ein bisschen ernst gemeint sein aber es
ist auf jeden fall übels krass ich mein
ich stell ab und zu mal so ein paar
videos rein und dass man damit wirklich
sollen vertrauen aufbauen kann hätte ich
jetzt nicht gedacht also ich habe mich
ehrlich ich wunder mich immer wenn ich
solche fragen kriege das ist irgendwie
komisch so ich bin sagen wir fangen mit
frage nummer 1 an und zwar leute diese
wie soll ich ein mädchen sagen dass ich
sie süß findet okay ich weiß dass meine
hauptzielgruppe so zwischen 13 und 15 16
jahren liegt und die etwas jüngeren sag
ich mal
ihr stellt euch das so schwer vor glaube
ich so das ist total schlimm ist oder so
ich mein also wenn mir jemand schreibt
dass er eine gewisse person süß findet
dann gehe schon davon aus dass er die
person mehr mag als vielleicht andere
personen und was ihr euch aber
eigentlich dazu sagen kann ist dass
jedes mädchen ist schon ein süß bzw
nett findet wenn man ihr überhaupt sagt
dass man sie süß findet und eigentlich
ist da gar nichts schlimmes dabei
also selbst wenn sie jetzt nicht
unbedingt gerade ob euch steht dann
sollte es dennoch eigentlich kein
problem sein wenn ihr sagt dass ihr sie
süß findet weil das eigentlich so 90
prozent aller mädchen auch süß finden
wenn man überhaupt sagt dass man sie süß
findet auch wenn sie vielleicht ein
bisschen davon ausgehen können dass ihr
etwas mehr für sie empfindet sag ich mal
habt keine angst vor macht das einfach
und mehr werdet ihr dann selber
herausfinden beziehungsweise sehen
reagiert ja jedes mädchen anders drauf
und
ja so viel zu dieser frage soll dann
kommen wir schon zur nächsten frage und
zwar lautet diese wie soll ich ein
mädchen fragen ob wir uns vielleicht mal
treffen können
ich weiß doch so 100 ganz genau wie ich
das bei meiner freundin gemacht weil sie
gefragt ob wir uns vielleicht mal
treffen können und zwar gibt es im
internet ganz viele bilder bestehen so
fünf punkte drauf und ihr erkennt das
doch bestimmt wenn ihr mit einem mädchen
schreibt und einfach jetzt kein
gesprächsthema findet und dann immer
schreibt ja so dumann gesprächsthema aus
oder du jetzt vielleicht und ja deswegen
gibt diese bilder wenn ich das doch
findet dann leicht dass man irgendwo
hoch und packt euch den linken in die
video beschreibung könnt ihr dann
einfach mal reinschauen ob der link da
drin ist auf jeden fall stehen also fünf
punkte drauf zum beispiel ihr könnt über
das reden oder über das also wenn euch
das mädchen fragt ja über was können wir
denn jetzt mal schreiben dann postet ihr
einfach das bild in diesen chat verlauf
und geht dann alle punkte durch und ganz
unten der letzte punkt ist können wir
uns vielleicht mal treffen oder
irgendwie sowas war das und dadurch
ergibt sich das ganze dann halt klingt
vielleicht ein kleines bisschen kindisch
oder so aber auf jeden fall wenn ihr so
zwischen 13 und 14 15 dann kann ich euch
das auf jeden fall empfehlen also ich
hoffe mal sollte klappen eigentlich und
dann kommen wir auch schon zur letzten
frage wie gut märz war noch nicht ganz
so oft gestellt aber dennoch ab und zu
und zwar lautet die ja ich stehe auf den
mädchen aber an die hat einen freund und
was soll ich jetzt machen ja also dazu
kann ich eigentlich nur sagen lasst es
am besten direkt sofort sein weil ihr
stellt euch nur unnötig in irgendwas
unnötiges rein und es fällt schwer da
wieder rauszukommen
denn vielleicht ein bisschen scheiße
aber ist so deswegen recht den kontakt
ab oder vermeidet es mit ihr zu
schreiben sei einfach meint das wäre
meine antwort auf diese frage ja so
leute ich hoffe ich konnte im einen oder
anderen vielleicht so ein bisschen rat
geben auf jeden fall was es mit dem
video ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen
falls es der fall ist würde ich mich
selber doch nach oben freuen ansonsten
instagram und co alles in der video
beschreibung check beim neuen facebook
seite auch in der video beschreibung und
hier auf der rechten seite geht es
weiter mit einem netz video das war mit
meiner freundin der
die airtec und hier auf der linken seite
auf der rechten seite das ist rechts und
links ja hier auf dieser seite kommt ihr
zu weiß nicht lasst euch überraschen und
ja wir sehen uns dann nächste woche
wieder schönes schönen sonntag noch
unklar